[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires sur tv5monde et sur vos
chaînes de la tnt voici tout de suite
les titres de l'actualité
voilà plusieurs jours que la garonne est
en crue conséquences des pluies
diluviennes qui se sont abattues dans ce
journal nous irons sur place avec nos
confrères devient occitanie mesurer
l'ampleur des dégâts dans un instant
dans ce journal vous entendrez le
témoignage poignant de louisa qui a
frôlé la mort après avoir contracté le
qu'ovide un co lead dur elle raconte son
émouvante histoire aux caméras de tl7 la
télévision de la loire
2,10 % c'est le taux d'inflation 2021
conséquence les prix dans l'alimentaire
ont gonflé c'est l'inquiétant constat
dressé par une équipe de via à tv en
martinique aux antilles qui a rencontré
des consommateurs mécontents vous le
verrez dans ce journal dans selon elle
également nos confrères de la dépêche
nous emmèneront dans le gers ou grichka
et igor bogdanoff décédés respectivement
le 28 décembre et le 3 janvier dernier
avait acquis un château dans les années
80 un château l'essai depuis à l'abandon
que nous visitons
en début de semaine météo france placé
cinq départements du sud ouest en
vigilance orange du fait d'un fort
risque de crue bien sûr et pour cause la
garonne qui est effectivement sorti de
son lit causant de nombreux dégâts
jonathan nausées et manon aussi devient
occitanie se sont rendus à cazères à une
soixantaine de kilomètres au sud de
toulouse pour rencontrer les sinistrés
regarder
une véritable cascade dans la ville rose
ce mardi à toulouse les caisses sont
inondés empêchant totalement leur accès
le niveau de l'eau atteint 3 mètres 50
le débit de la garonne a été multiplié
par 15 depuis lundi
plus au sud du département la crue de la
garonne a surpris les habitants de
cazères ce lundi soir de nombreuses
maisons ont été inondées durant la nuit
sur le quai des fusillés une dizaine de
personnes ont été évacuées par les
pompiers d'autres se sont réfugiés à
l'étagé de leur maison l'eau est montée
en quelques minutes en une demi-heure
une heure on s'est retrouvé avec l'eau
qui rentre et déjà la maison donc
il ya dû avoir 30 40 cm en très peu de
temps on avait les stores fermés et sa
rentrée sa rentrée et c'est monté
jusqu'à 2h du mat et qu'avec ce qui
flottait les bouteilles de verre le
garage d'une pièce où il ya tout
l'électroménager tout ça ça a pris plus
d'un mètre d'eau ici dans le salon jeudi
le canapé flotter saleh jusqu'à la table
du salon à hauteur de mémoire d'homme
certains habitants n'avait pas vu un tel
phénomène depuis 70 ans cette crue a dû
dépasser
en intensité ce qui s'était passé le 2
février 52 si j'ai bonne mémoire à
cazères les dégâts sont matériels mais
il n'y a pas eu de blessés sur météo
france mardi le gers le tarn et garonne
les hautes pyrénées la haute garonne
reste en vigilance orange crues au moins
jusqu'à mercredi matin
voilà puis sur le front de la coved se
faire vacciner de 19h à 3h du matin un
dimanche c'est désormais possible enfin
uniquement à sarrola carcopino en corse
à 15 kilomètres d'ajaccio où vient
d'être ouvert un centre de vaccination
24 heures sur 24 et 7 jours sur 7 dont
voici ici quelques images prises par
angelina rossano de télé pas aisée une
première en france qui donnera peut-être
des idées à d'autres
voilà les puits covit 19 toujours céline
r s'il y a de tl7 la chaîne de la loire
a rencontré louisa alibert qui a bien
failli comme je vous le disais en titre
être emporté par la maladie aujourd'hui
elles qui étaient réfractaires à la
vaccination a vraiment changé de
discours vous allez voir un témoignage
édifiant
[Musique]
cette discussion entre mère et fille
aurait pu ne pas se produire si
aujourd'hui louisa alibert peut profiter
de ses proches c'est grâce aux médecins
et à sa volonté de battante en été
dernier elle contracte locaux vides 19
elle avait fait le choix de ne pas se
faire vacciner parce que j'entendais
quel manga gens autour de moi n'diaye
mais ça sert à rien c'est et tout mon
mari l'a fait m'appuie la paix j'aurais
dû écouter mon mari victime avait pris
rendez vous pour faire le vaccin effet
pas voulu j'en étais qu'à ma tête et
j'ai payé les conséquences très vite
elle tombe dans le coma trois mois en
réanimation suivi de trois autres mois
d'hospitalisation à plusieurs reprises
elle frôlé le pire jusqu'à présent je
n'arrive pas à comprendre
comment vont ses sorties franchement où
finalement il ya toujours un miracle
dans la vie il faut il croire une
épreuve traversés aussi par ses proches
comme sa fille mélissa et quand ça l'est
vraiment vers la première fois dans
comme moi c'est waou séjour j'ai créé la
plus grosse claque mais la plus grosse
claque de manille on se rend pas compte
on dit que ça arrive qu aux autres même
jour où ça arrive à moi enfin à nous
puis comme moi c'est pas beau en fait
elle est branché de partout à l'est elle
est gonflée et puis on ne sait ce
qu'elle nous en tant est qu'elle est là
enfin pour moi le seul problème c'est
comme si elle était comme ça a été une
seconde donc c était ça a été très
éprouvant fia nous a fait des arrêts
cardiaques
luisa a pu finalement sortir de
l'hôpital le 24 décembre dernier mais le
chemin de la guérison est encore long
mais médecins lui ont implanté une pile
au coeur elle n'a toujours pas retrouvé
le goût et l'odorat elle a toujours des
difficultés pour se déplacer mais
poursuit ses efforts son objectif
redevenir la femme dynamique qu'elle
était et pour cela elle passera en mars
prochain par la case vaccination voilà
et puis sur le sujet sensible de
l'ouverture des discothèques suivez
sensible pour les jeunes jean roch du
vip room à saint tropez qu'à rencontrer
les équipes de nice matin à poser une
question cette semaine dans face aux
territoires ou ministre chargé du
tourisme justement jean baptiste lemoyne
ont l'écoutent
bonjour monsieur le ministre une simple
petite question
je m'interroge sur la position prise par
le premier ministre anglais monsieur
boris johnson de laisser toutes ouvert
en angleterre restaurant bar aucune
limitation est également les
discothèques et ça continue fonctionner
sa position par rapport au virus par
rapport à l'aco vide et scènes de créer
une unité collective
raison ou tort je pense que tout le
monde navigue à vue que personne n'a la
réponse mais je voulais savoir vous quel
était votre sentiment par rapport à ça
alors en fait on a voulu prendre des
mesures de freinage pour pouvoir tout
simplement éviter l'engorgement des
hôpitaux jean roch diva félins au
royaume uni tout est resté ouvert
globalement et ça continue à tourner
mais le royaume uni en matière
hospitalière
je dirais à peut-être des pratiques un
petit peu différente c'est à dire que
quand vous êtes une personne très âgée
et que vous arrivez potentiellement pour
être placé en réanimation je vois là ce
que je comprends de la politique de
santé c'est que en france on fait tout
pour sauver tout le monde voilà quels
que soient l'âge et que manifestement
la façon de pratiquer les au royaume uni
est peut-être un peu différente ce qui
explique aussi certaines décisions voilà
et puis tout à fait autre chose dans
l'actualité je vous le disais dans les
titres d'après les chiffres de l'insee
l'inflation en france en 2021 et de 2,8
pour cent un taux qui reflète une
réalité bien difficile notamment pour
nos compatriotes martiniquais rencontré
là-bas par robin parisse de via à tv aux
antilles
les produits frais ce sont eux les plus
touchés par le renchérissement des prix
à la consommation avec une hausse
moyenne de 2% ils deviennent presque
hors de prix pour le consommateur
la vie est devenue votre
ville et à
chaud très chaud sauver ou tu fais des
courses
dans cette étude de l'insee les prix de
l'alimentation progressent de 0,9 pour
cent entre juillet et novembre 2021 les
prix de l'énergie ont aussi flambé avec
près de 17% pour la bouteille de gaz en
l'espace de quelques mois l'énergie
subit donc la plus forte hausse mais
c'est bien dans leur panier repas que
les foyers vont essayer de se rattraper
on joue sur l'alimentation et on réduit
sur l'alimentation et c'est vrai qu'on
constate une hausse des prix importante
pour un panier je dirais
ordinaire on est passé il ya presqu'un
an de 80 euros à au début d'année à 150
euros à 100 à 100 euros est maintenant à
150 euros la publication de l'insee
interpelle et corroborent la plainte
justifiée d'une vie trop chère en
martinique
la problématique de la vie chère est
vraie elle parce qu'il y à des dérapages
de prix sur des éléments essentiels de
la vie des martiniquais et il faut des
réponses la vie chère c'est pas une
illusion il ya suffisamment
denquête même nom a été entreprise nous
avons démontré en début d'année que non
seulement la confirmation de la vie
chère mais il y à des actions qui
peuvent être menées pour baisser
rapidement de 20% certains produits de
première nécessité un avertissement
supplémentaire sur la situation des
martiniquais et beaucoup espèrent des
mesures concrètes pour 2022
et puis également dans l'actualité les
prix de l'alimentaire augmente mais
également ceux du carburant jérôme
houbron de web tv la chaîne de la voix
du nord a tendu son micro à des
automobilistes amiénois qui lui ont
donné leurs petites astuces leur recette
pour faire baisser la facture
regardez c'est toujours bon à prendre
nouveau coup dur pour les automobilistes
en ce début d'année 2022 le prix du
carburant continue sa flambée en
seulement deux semaines le litre de
diesel ou d'essence voit son coût
augmenter d'environ 5 centimes
maintenant ils déposent pas en dessous
des 1 euro 50 ans et au dessus donc
moi je fais 30 km matin 30 km au soir 60
km je veux dire à la journée ça commence
à peser dans le budget la chine dans une
station en plein centre ville c'est
encore je pense les plus chers que j'ai
vu et là je vais mettre que 10 euros
parce que ça me paraît beaucoup trop
élevé à 1 euros 69 le litre le sans
plomb 95 affichent une augmentation
record de 21 % en un an +24 % pour le
diesel à 1 euros 62 litres une hausse
constante conséquences d'une crise
sanitaire qui s'éternise alors pour
faire des économies toutes les astuces
sont bienvenus bon on réduit un peu on
essaye de faire en sorte de réduire les
trajets on a pris l'habitude de faire
les trajets qu'on pouvait faire à pied
dans le temps on le fait tout le temps à
en voiture acheter un véhicule neuf
passer à l'électrique en matière
d'économie les offres ne manquent pas
mais voilà certaines solutions restent
onéreuses dans ce garage amiénois il
faut compter entre 200 et 600 euros pour
convertir son véhicule au bioéthanol
carburant certes bien moins cher les peu
connu on va dire aujourd'hui j'ai de la
demande du rallye une voiture par mois
je trouve c'est très peu après et après
cinq ans en moins c'est beaucoup moins
cher c'est plus intéressant à
charge et a maintenu la note
malheureusement pour les adeptes du
moteur thermique les prix du carburant
risque fort de se maintenir plusieurs
semaines dans un contexte de crise
sanitaire c'est peut-être le télétravail
qui restera le moins coûteux
et puis comme vous le savez sans doute
la crise économique touche et étudiants
de plein fouet certains vivent en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté 40% même
d'entre eux envisagent d'arrêter leurs
études alors un peu partout en france
des initiatives sont mises en place pour
tenter de les aider comme à bordeaux
vous allez le voir où leur sont remis
des colis alimentaires aurélie chiale
vos de tv7 a assisté à une distribution
sur place regarder
survivre et s'alléger d'un fardeau
financier lorsqu'on est étudiant c'est
ce qui a conduit lilia à s'inscrire
auprès du crous pour pouvoir bénéficier
de collier alimentaires que les bourses
vont payer mon logement et
tout ce qui est alimentaire personnel
etc et
les courses ça quand même budget je le
vois quand je dois acheter des trucs en
plus comme elle ils sont un peu plus de
3000 en situation précarité dans toute
la métropole bordelaise mais la plupart
des étudiants bénéficiaires sont
étrangers les ténèbres financier laisse
un mais deux locaux la distribution
alimentaire et hebdomadaire chaque
étudiant reçoit deux colis de 5 kg soit
l'équivalent de 18 repas on dispose il
parlerait d'un couscous ce terrain ça
dépend de la saison pour assurer une
distribution optimale
l'approvisionnement est réalisée auprès
de plusieurs donateurs étudiants de
lenteur qui nous ont offert près de 900
kg
de
dentifrice de brosses à dents de
produits d'hygiène dentaire des
associations locales aussi sur talence
où sont venues apporter des colis malgré
la générosité des donateurs en 2021 la
banque alimentaire a constaté une baisse
effective de 15% sur 20 mille tonnes de
denrées alimentaires habituellement
fournis par la grande distribution
voilà après les étudiants les seniors
coup de projecteur dans ce journal sur
un ehpad à guingamp où l'on ne parle pas
de résident mais d'habitants une nuance
qui a son importance et que nous
explique mathilde de quemener de tvr
vous voulez couper les fruits albert
thill comme à la maison ses résidentes
et de l'ehpad de kersalic à guingamp
participe à l'élaboration du repas ici
elles sont d'ailleurs considérés comme
des habitantes pour souligner leur rôle
actif moi ça me plaît et puis j'aime
bien
j'aime bien piqué dedans aussi vivre
comme à la maison voilà avec des repères
comme abba préparation des repas des
informations passer le balai enfin voilà
tout ce qu'on faisait à la maison à leur
époque et dans l'équipe soignante une
infirmière peut devenir une aide
soignante mais ici on essaie de se
mélanger autant les soignants ont peut
être un jour donc faire des prises
enfants mais le lendemain à peut très
bien voilà être en animation cet ehpad
est pensé comme un véritable village
cours de tai-chi de percussions épicerie
et bien sûr brasserie chacun peut y
réserver une place et invité ses proches
et pour y aller certaines se mettent sur
leur 31
moules frites
là on voulait vraiment proposer une
prestation de restaurants dans un
service à la carte avec des produits de
qualité
locaux bio fait maison et cuisson minute
grâce à tous ces changements les
antidépresseurs ont été divisés par deux
dans l'établissement pour la directrice
ces personnes ont certes des troubles
cognitifs mais elles sont encore en vie
et ont des hanches alors on est
peut-être un peu novateur mais nous
depuis déjà 2015 on est dans les pattes
du futur ont reproduit tout simplement
la vie de l'extérieur à l'intérieur
un fonctionnement qui fait le bonheur
des habitants mais aussi des soignants
ici la direction n'a aucun problème de
recruteurs
voilà comme vous le savez les jumeaux
les plus célèbres de france igor et
grichka bogdanoff ont été emportés par
l'aco vide et inhumé le 10 janvier
dernier agnès grimaldi nos confrères de
la dépêche et ses équipes se sont
rendues sur leurs terres dans le gers où
il avait acquis en 1986 le château death
caignac raymond vall le maire de
fleurance une commune voisine se
remémorent les bons moments passés là
bas écoutez c'était une famille qui
avait adopté le gers et qui donnait
l'impression de vraiment se plaire dans
ce cadre magnifique il faut dire que le
château des scuds ac est bâti sur les
anciennes ruines romaines il ya même des
traces de bains romains
il y à vraiment nature avec d une
végétation et des armes fantastique et
je me rappelle de table et qu'on faisait
à l'extérieur on était une vingtaine
autour de cette table et j'ai
l'impression quand même qu'il y avait
une forte communion entre
le père et ses enfants et quelques
petits enfants déjà qu'on voyait voilà
pour ce reportage reste maintenant à
mettre d'accord les onze héritiers des
jumeaux à savoir les cinq frères et
soeurs de grichka et les six enfants
d'igor quant à l'avenir de ce château
tout à fait autre chose dans l'actualité
alors que l'on compte en france quelques
400 boutiques vendant du cbd un des
constituants du cannabis un arrêté daté
du 31 décembre interdit désormais la
vente de feuilles et de fleurs de
chambre une nouvelle qui vous pensez ne
ravit pas les professionnels comme ivan
que fanny bragard de moselle tv a
rencontré pour nous
fans de baudelaire et vendeurs de cbd il
vend n'imaginais pas que sa boutique les
fleurs du mâle porte si bien son nom
depuis le 1er janvier l'état français
lui interdit de commercialiser les
fleurs et feuilles de ce dérivé du
cannabis pourtant l'égal de c'était une
question de santé publique comme le
disent en fait tu vas y laisseraient il
serait s'est produit ce vendredi
comme dans n'importe quel autre pays de
l'union européenne donc c'est pour ça
que c'est un peu c'est très
contradictoires leurs arrêtés c'est là
tout le problème cet arrêté français se
heurte au droit européen qui ne
considère pas le cannabis violent comme
un stupéfiant temps qu'il contient moins
de 0,3 pour cent de thc désireux
d'exercer en toute légalité ivan a fait
analyser chacune des en société de
fleurs qu'ils proposaient à la vente ça
c'est la plus élevée que j'ai donc c
lojie tech donc elle est à 0 18 % de thc
ça sent qu en termes d'effets qui est
0,06 ou 0,18 c'est exactement la même
chose
ouvert en juin dernier son commerce
florissant pourrait ne pas survivre à
cette interdiction on va essayer de
faire sortir avec les autres produits et
puis on verra bien même si c'est
théoriquement c'est pas possible quoi
parce que 60% du chiffre d'affaires on
ne peut pas le rattraper
enfin sur un produit pour le rattraper
les autres quoi pour moi ça va être
compliqué d'autant plus compliquée que
la vente d'un fusion est elle aussi
interdite or elle représentait 5 à 7%
des ventes divan au placard donc fleurs
et infusions mais peut-être pas pour
toujours loin de calmer le jeu autour du
cbd cet arrêté devrait laisser place à
une nouvelle bataille juridique les
professionnels du secteur s'apprête à
déposer des recours devant le conseil
d'état
je vous propose dans ce journal
maintenant de découvrir l'étonnant
projet de maxime perrottet photographe
habitants de saint dié des vosges qui a
décidé de tout quitter et de ne vivre
qu'avec le strict minimum
un reportage n'aurait ni colombelles et
de thierry lasson devos télévision qui
sont allés voir avec lui quel était son
quotidien
hormis pour le guen avait sa ces données
données de ce bel appartement déodatien
ne restera bientôt plus que des pièces
vides maxime a décidé de tout quitter et
vivre avec le strict nécessaire
l'accumulent certaines choses et on perd
peut-être un petit peu l'essence même de
nos vies et je me dis peut-être que dans
quelques jours la chose la plus
importante pour moi ça sera une bougie
ou le feu que j'aurais à mes pieds et
voilà j'ai besoin d'aller rechercher sa
quelque chose de plus ancré dans le réel
c'est donc sur des sites forestiers qui
s'installera avec son 4 4 aménagé
photographe triathlète et amateurs de
défis en parallèle il poursuivra ses
activités professionnelles sur le
secteur de saint dié tout en se donnant
neuf mois pour satisfaire son besoin d'
aventure un dépassement de soi sa crise
de la quarantaine le coc vie dans l'est
on est un élément déclencheur ou là
peut-être un petit peu cristalliser les
confinements cette
complicité de vivre qu'on peut ressentir
en ce moment donc c'est une chose j'ai
la possibilité de le faire aussi famille
amis employeurs mi amusé mi inquiet sont
à ses côtés reste à confier son chat une
présence qui va lui manquer les affaires
propres elles seraient elles se
réduiront assez simplement à quelques
tee-shirts quelques pulls
quelques qu'elles sont un appareil photo
et un ordinateur portable une démarche
artistique accompagne ce projet l'envi
de faire des clichés en pleine nature à
son rythme c'est prendre du temps pour
se balader être contemplatif ça fait un
peu ermite comme ça mais être
contemplatif des choses pouvoir profiter
et rien que les regarder c'est parfois
important de regarder bon vu quelqu'un
comme moi c'est important de regarder
les choses et puis c'est des journées
qui vont être aussi assez remplie parce
que tout sera plus compliqué en termes
de gestion des temps au programme
accomplir les rêves toujours repoussée à
plus tard
première étape admirer les aurores
boréales en laponie une aventure à
suivre
direction dans ce journal la bretagne
maintenant et plus précisément lannion
où un drôle de bateau aussi luxueux
qu'écologique a vu le jour une naissance
auquel mathilde de kenner noté bo la
chaîne du groupe le télégramme insisté
regarder il y a quatre ans un drôle de
bateau faisait sensation au port de
trébeurden un bateau rompt avec vision
sous marine et terrasse à l'étagé un
concept tiré d'un film de james pants en
1977 j'avais 17 ans il ya une capsule
dans ce film où j'ai ce bond et sagesse
dongles échappe à la fin et j'y tiens un
jour ferait créer ça un rêve qui devient
des décennies plus tard réalité l'usiné
désormais construites à lannion est le
premier bateau prend ici bon aujourd'hui
maintenant chacun a compris que quand tu
es neri passer au stade industriel on a
une très belle usine qui nous a été
livré par damian trégor communauté et
donc nous avons commencé la construction
du numéro un qui va être livré au qatar
au printemps prochain à doha et ce sera
une vitrine extraordinaire puisqu'il
sera arrivé avant la coupe du monde de
football donc chacun tous les visiteurs
du monde entier pourront voir dans le
port le premier au tdr une
concrétisation pourtant il y a quelques
mois le projet était mise à mal par la
crise sanitaire des clients se sont
retirés mais d'autres sont apparus et
finalement on s'est aperçu assez vite et
les médias l'ont dit le premier les
premiers que
antennes et a est un produit covit
friendly et donc c'est vrai assez vite
et effectivement c'est une évidence
c'est un vraiment à côté des très gros
paquebot par exemple quand et 5000
personnes peut-être même plus sur un
bateau c'est énorme alors que si on
imagine un complexe antennes et a par
exemple eh bien chacun est indépendant
pour l'instant 15 salariés ont été
embauchés et cinq recrutements sont
prévus en ce mois de janvier à terme les
associés prévoit une quarantaine de
salariés sur site pour fabriquer une
vingtaine d'antenne et à chaque année
voilà depuis le palais des papes à
avignon se refait une beauté les 3500 m²
de façade du somptueux bâtiment gothique
du moyen âge sont nettoyées à l'aide
huiles essentielles de citron de
géranium et de menthe
le saviez vous une technique que
l'insolite qui mérite tout de même une
petite explication qui est allé
recueillir pour nous adrillon pommier de
la provence nos confrères sur place
auprès de la restauratrice carole
sanchez
là on est sur un traitement curatif
préventif
qui est donc à base d'huiles
essentielles ces huiles essentielles
sont composés donc de citronnelle menthe
et géraniums
on les applique
principalement sur tout ce qui est tout
la prolifération micro micro organismes
type lichens mousse qu'on peut voir ici
sur le palais des pâtes et ses huiles
essentielles vont nous permettre donc de
d'altérer le lichen pour que celui ci
soit fragilisée au et être plus
facilement retiré à la vapeur et a fait
et donc le choix de la vapeur c'est
aussi un choix pour une de conservation
de l'épiderme parce qu'il est non
abrasif c'est une technique non invasive
et puis on joue une page de ce sport
dans ce journal maintenant cette fin du
mois de janvier où les grands noms du
football ont rendez vous à monaco pour
la first aid cup un événement caritatif
organisé par louis ducruet le fils de la
princesse stéphanie de monaco que
yannick des verts de monaco à fond a
rencontré
on a bossé comme des dingues de la
devine rien
fait d'aluminium et de feuilles d'or
cette faille tandis que paie tout
simplement splendide elle est l'oeuvre
du sculpteur stéphane cipre sollicité
par l'association
l'idée en fait c'était de voir le logo
fighters et d'avoir le reflet de de
l'oeuvre du bloc en fait qui reflète les
les spectateurs et le stade et tout ce à
quoi il a fallu un travail d'une semaine
jour et nuit dans son atelier de saint
andré de la roche avec son binôme pour
élever ce trophée sculpture une pièce
unique qui plaît forcément aux
organisateurs de la faillite et scope un
magnifique exceptionnel surtout dans le
temps imparti qu'on a demandé à
l'artiste de faire fesser trophée je
trouve ça magnifique et au delà des
attentes qu'on avait pour ce pour ce
trophée donc on est ravi ce trophée je
les pendus à 3 heures du matin j'ai
présenté des premiers des premières
esquisses à louis on a travaillé
ensemble et après j'ai présenté ce
dessin et j'ai dit à mon avis et ça
c'est l'événement caritatif principal du
début d'année à monaco un match de foot
où sont réunis des légendes du ballon
rond dans deux équipes les barbadiens du
prince albert et le cirque fc de la
princesse stéphanie cette année encore
de très grands noms comme cy d'or
faisait cardo luca toni mais aussi des
petits nouveaux qui ont fait le bonheur
des monégasques fernando morientes qui
fait son grand retour au stade louis 2
on à david trezeguet aussi n'a claude
puel qui n' est qu' t'es pas là la
première édition on à bruno bellone
jérôme rothen françois modesto pour
l'équipe des barbades gens et les noms
donne l'eau à la bouche et même si 2022
ne sera que la deuxième édition les
organisateurs de la fight aids scop
compte bien faire de cet événement un
rendez vous annuel important de la
principauté en rendez vous lundi 24
janvier à 18h30 au stade louis ii pour
savoir qui soulèvera ce magnifique
trophée
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de nous avoir suivi sur vos chaînes de
la tnt en région ou sur tv5 monde on se
retrouve très vite pour une prochaine
édition aura tous
[Musique]